in this video we're going to talk about
extraneous solutions if you've never
heard the term before i encourage you to
review some videos on khan academy on
extraneous solutions but just as a bit
of a refresher it's the idea that you do
a bunch of legitimate algebraic
operations you get a solution or some
solutions at the end but then when you
test it in the original equation it
doesn't satisfy the original equation
and so the key of this video is why do
extraneous solutions even occur
and it all is due to the notion of
reversibility
there's certain operations in
algebra that you can do in one direction
but you can't and it'll always be true
in one direction but it isn't always the
true it isn't always true in the other
direction and i'll show you those two
operations one is squaring and the other
is multiplying both sides by a variable
expression so let's see the example of
squaring and then we're going to see it
in an actual scenario where you're
dealing with an extr with an extraneous
solution
so we know for example that if a is
equal to b
i could square
both sides
and then a squared is going to be equal
to b squared
but the other way is not true
for example
if a squared is equal to b squared
it is not always
the case that a is equal to b what's an
example that shows that this is not
always the case but actually pause the
video try to think about it
well
negative 2 squared is indeed equal to 2
squared but negative 2 is not equal to
2. so this shows that you can square the
both sides of both you can square both
sides of an equation and get and deduce
something that is
true but the other way around is not
necessarily going to be true
another non-reversible operation
sometimes is multiplying both sides by a
variable expression
so multiplying both
sides actually that gets confused looks
like an x
multiply
both
sides
by
variable i'll just write variable but it
could be a variable expression as well
for example
we know that if a is equal to b
that if we multiply both sides by a
variable that's still going to be true
x a is going to be equal to
x b
but the other the reverse isn't always
the case if x a is equal to xb
is it always the case that a is equal to
b
well the simple answer is no and i
always encourage you pause this video
and see if you can find out an example
where this doesn't work
well what if the var if a was 2 and b is
3 and the variable x just happened to
take on the value 0. so we know that 0
times 2 is indeed equal to 0 times 3 but
2
is not equal to 3. now how does all this
connect to the extraneous solutions
you've seen when you're solving radical
equations or when you're solving some
rational or equations with rational
expressions on both sides let's look at
an example let's solve a radical
equation
if i wanted to solve the equation
the square root
of 5 x minus 4
is equal to x minus 2. a typical first
step is hey let's get rid of this
radical by squaring both sides
so i am going to square
both sides and then i'm going to get 5x
minus 4 is equal to x squared minus 4x
plus 4. once again if this looks
completely unfamiliar to you we go into
much more depth in other videos where we
introduce the idea of radical equations
and let's see we can subtract 5x from
both sides we can add 4 to both sides
i'm just trying to get a 0 on the
left-hand side and so i'm going to be
left with zero is equal to x squared
minus nine x plus eight
or zero is equal to x minus eight times
x minus one
or we could say that x minus one is
equal to zero or
x minus eight is equal to zero
we get x equals one or x equals eight
so let's test these solutions if x
equals eight we would get and i'll color
code it a little bit for x equals 8 if i
test it in the original equation i get
the square root of 36 is equal to 6
which is absolutely true so that one
works but what about x equals 1
i get the square root of 5 times 1 minus
4 is 1
is equal to 1 minus 2 which is equal to
negative 1.
that did not work this right over here
is an extraneous solution if someone
said what are all the x values that
satisfy this equation you would not say
x equals one even though you got there
with legitimate algebraic steps and the
reason that is true is actually pause
this video look back for which of these
steps does x equals one x equal one
still work and what step does it not
work
well you'll see
that x equals 1 works for all of these
equations below this purple line it just
doesn't work for the square root of 5
minus 4x is equal to x minus 2. in fact
you can start with x minus 1 and then
you could deduce all the way up to this
line here
but the issue here is that squaring is
not a reversible operation this is
analogous to saying hey we know that a
squared is equal to b squared we know
that this is equal to this
but then that doesn't mean that a is
necessarily equal to b for x equals 1.
and we could do the same thing with a
rational or an equation that deals with
rational expressions
so for example we might have to deal
with and let me make sure i have some
space here
if i had to solve
x squared over x minus 1 is equal to 1
over x minus 1. the first thing i might
want to do is multiply both sides by x
minus 1. so multiply
multiply
by x minus 1. now notice i'm multiplying
both sides by a variable expression so
we have to be a little bit conscientious
now but if i multiply both sides by x
minus 1 i'm going to get x squared is
equal to 1
or i could say that x equals 1 or x is
equal to negative 1.
but we could test these for x equals 1
if i go up here i'm dividing by 0 on
both sides so this is an extraneous
solution
the key here is that we multiplied both
sides by a variable expression in this
case we multiplied both sides by x minus
1.
you can do that you can multiply both
sides by a variable expression and it is
a legitimate algebraic operation it's
completely analogous to what we saw
right over here
just because 0 times 2 is equal to 0
times 3 does not mean that 2 is equal to
3. it's completely analogous because we
multiplied by a variable expression that
actually takes on the value 0 when x is
equal to 1.
so the big takeaway here is hopefully
you understand why extraneous solutions
happen a little bit more when you square
when you multiply both sides by variable
expression completely legitimate as long
as you do it properly but it's not
always the case that the reverse is true
you can add or subtract anything from
both sides of an equation and that's
always going to be reversible and so you
don't that's not going to lead to
extraneous solutions you can multiply or
divide by a non-zero constant value
that's also not going to lead to
anything shady but if you're squaring
both sides or multiplying both sides by
a variable expression you should be a
little bit careful